Barry Weiss quits the New York Times and
sets fire to the building on her way out
Andrew Sullivan exits in New York
magazine and the editor sounds off and
Andrew Cuomo slams AOC I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from prying eyes at
expressvpn comm /ban well you may have
noticed things are kind of uncertain
right look like we're reopening the
economy and then out here in California
governor Newsom was like we're gonna
stop that right now no more of the
reopening of the economy it seems like
there's covered up ticks here but what
exactly is gonna happen next is vexy not
who the hell knows nobody knows anything
that is the theme of this year 2020
nobody knows bleep which is why you
should probably buy diversified at least
a little bit into precious metals the
market has come a long way since coven
nineteen hit it is still down over eight
percent for the year Gold is up 18
percent this year why well because
people diversified and also because
people recognize that uncertainty is not
really great for your bank account Birch
gold is the place to go if you are
interested in diversifying into precious
metals Birch gold has an A+ rating with
the Better Business Bureau hundreds of
five-star reviews they have the precious
metal experts that will hold your hand
walk you through the transitioning of
one of your eligible IRAs or 401 k's
into an IRA in gold or silver if that's
something you are interested in it's
still an election year we're seeing a
massive resurgence in cubben 19
unemployment is still extremely high
lots of uncertainty out there that
versifying into precious metals is the
smart thing to do texe been to 47 47 47
when you open an IRA in precious metals
before July 31st you get a signed copy
of my book the right side of history for
free again text my name Ben - 47 47 47
and hook up with the precious metal
experts I trust text Ben - 47 47 47 then
ask all your questions and then invest
with Virgil okay so we'll give you the
brief news update because there's a lot
of news out there today before we even
get to everything related to the
complete meltdown over at the New York
Times the meltdown in mainstream media
and the complete redefinition of the
media itself which is a pretty damned
big story we'll get to that in a second
but first a couple of pieces of rather
large scale news first Supreme Court
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg according to
CNBC was hospitalized Tuesday for a
possible infection she's been in and out
of the hospital for at least two three
years at this point
she's now 87 years old she received
treatment at Johns Hopkins Hospital in
Baltimore after experiencing fever and
chills she underwent a procedure to
clean a bile duct stent and will stay in
the hospital for a few days
according to her spokesperson the
Justice is resting comfortably and will
stay in the hospital for a few days to
receive intravenous antibiotic treatment
in January she was cancer-free after
undergoing treatment
it was likely pancreatic cancer last
year the year before she had treatment
for cancer on her lungs so it's been a
health mess for Ruth Bader Ginsburg
obviously everybody praying for her
health although some of us would like to
see her step down voluntarily from the
Supreme Court because two things can be
true once I want her to be healthy and
also I think she's a terrible justice
but certainly the writers of 20/20 have
Trump season 5 they've really decided to
pull out all the stops here if you can
just imagine a Supreme Court vacancy
which you know god forbid it should
happen through something that happening
through with better Ginsburg but if she
were to step down for any reason for any
reason if there is a Supreme Court
vacancy in this election year oh my god
the hellish riots that will occur as a
result of replacement Ruth Bader
Ginsburg with Amy Kony Barrett for
example would just be insane meanwhile
we've been watching this coven uptick in
the relock down of California so Los
Angeles is completely locked down again
virtually all businesses have been
shuttered you're still allowed to eat
outdoors but pretty much it all indoor
businesses have been shut down including
hair salons including restaurants
including pretty much everything like
all the things have been shut down
across the state of California and LA
announced that they would not be
reopening the schools in August so
basically you're gonna be learning from
home again which is really a stop to the
teachers union because the data on
students and and how healthy they are
and how much code affects them it is it
is pretty non-conflicting when it comes
to the health of the students the real
problem with opening schools is teachers
and administrators which is why the
suggestion that I've made my friend John
pod it's over the commentary
magazine podcast made it and someone a
copy him I think is a good idea let me
bring the kids back and if you have
older teachers who are incapable of
being in the classroom for health
reasons then you have them zoom in but
the idea that all these kids are gonna
stay home and then they're going to be
able to do zoom classes is just
completely insane so la has completely
shut it down at San Diego apparently
shut it down as well Orange County on
the other hand says that they are going
to attempt to reopen what is the status
of coronavirus today so I have good news
and I have bad news so which one you
want first which one you offer you know
I'll give you the good news first
because I think that you're getting
enough of the bad news from the media
and frankly I think the media are over
playing some of the bad news they're
implying that we are in exactly the same
place we were back in April or March
that we are about to see this New York
type surge across the country that
overwhelms the healthcare system the
data on that is extremely limited it
does not look at this point as the
Florida is gonna be overwhelmed it does
not look
Texas is gonna be overwhelmed it doesn't
look as though California is going to be
overwhelmed
it looks instead as though there has
been a surge in positive tests although
that may be plateauing and it is also
true that the the identification of the
positive is a lot higher than it was
back in March or April it is likely that
we were actually wildly under
identifying positive cases back in March
or April we are now running in like a
six day period seven day period as many
tests for covin 19 as we ran in all of
2017 2018 and 2019 combined for the flu
you know like a seven day period that's
how many tests we are running across the
country now that's good I mean it means
that we're identifying the cases it also
means that we are getting a better
picture of the actual infection fatality
rate you know how many people have it
versus how many people are dying and
that's why even as you see the numbers
rising from last week as far as the
number of people dying and that is a
trailing indicator usually it's anywhere
from two weeks to a month trailing
indicator those numbers in proportions
the number of cases have actually been
declining so you've been seeing at the
same time an absolute rise in death so
it's talked about a thousand yesterday
according to Johns Hopkins and the or at
least a thousand reported again the
reporting procedures here are a little
bit confused because sometimes there are
people who are back dating right there
they're taking a death from two weeks
ago they realize now it was Cove it and
now they're reporting it that way it
there's a bit of a lag time in other
words but whatever you say there has
been a surge in deaths over the past
week or so but as a percentage of total
infections the rates have actually gone
down and you've seen a decreasing
positivity rate in places like Florida
and Texas over the last few days as well
so the notion that we are about to be
just overwhelmed with death in the
system the data on that is pretty scanty
in fact what we might be looking at and
here here's the optimist in me well we
might be looking at is I would hope a
plateauing all right when our hope is a
plateauing and this brings us to peace
of possible good news number one that is
the dare is a theory that is out there
and it is now being increasingly backed
by data from of all places Sweden right
Sweden the worst country on earth
because Sweden didn't really shut down
they sort of allowed people to go out
they basically allowed young people to
go out they told older people stay home
and their big mistake was they didn't
protect nursing homes very early but
they basically followed the same
protocols that Florida did without
protecting the nursing homes they said
that if you want to go out wear a mask
socially distance but life has to go on
and Sweden was heavily criticized
for this their their deaths per million
were compared unfavorably with places
like Norway with places like Denmark
that were next door but Sweden is now
seeing an increased number of cases and
almost no death so this has led people
to suggest what exactly is going on here
Randy normally you would see increased
number of cases an increased number of
deaths so what exactly is going on in
Sweden well the data sort of suggests
that maybe the herd immunity rate is not
60 percent maybe the herd immunity rate
isn't even 40 percent maybe in fact the
herd immunity rate is like 10 to 20
percent right which would explain by the
way why New York State is not seeing a
vast uptick in number of deaths even as
they reopen is why New Jersey isn't
seeing fast optics and death once they
reopen in other words once this thing
runs through your population it's pretty
much done I mean that would be the great
hope here and that's sort of what you're
seeing in Sweden how could that be
because normally herd immunity is 60 70
80 percent how could it be that herd
immunity would be like 10 or 20 percent
or something called T cell immunity Jim
Garrity over at National Review wrote
about this yesterday he says the
Guardian over in the UK has reported on
a study by King's College London
suggesting that after infection
coronavirus patients could lose their
built-in immunity to reinfection fairly
quickly and then in box there's a guy
named clay Ackerley in internal medicine
and primary care physician practicing in
Washington DC who described a 50 year
old patient who tested positive suffered
effects of coronavirus tested negative
twice then tested positive again with
more severe symptoms a second time about
six weeks later and there were these
worries earlier in the year but those
those words were about South Korea the
South Korean CDC reported that you might
be able to be reinfected with all of
this but there are some data that came
out from this and the data that came out
from this is that maybe it turns out
that this person's immune system these
immunities secondary sort of infections
that that was actually just a reflection
of the first infection that actually
what is happening here is that some
people have a pre-existing resistance to
coronavirus so as Jim Garrity writes the
body's response to a viral infection
utilizes both antibodies and T cells
which may have heard of in the context
of cancer treatments T cells are
produced in bone marrow but get their
name because they develop in the thymus
gland T cells are basically the Special
Forces of your immune system split into
two groups the first cd8 acts as Navy
SEALs of your immune system they take on
affections virus bacteria tumors and God
willing take them all down the second
category of t-cells cd4 are the support
staff performing a variety of duties
including the protection of cytokines
remember cytokine storms that this is
the idea that the the body was reacting
too fast to kovat nineteen it was
actually shutting down systems in the
body our body's production of t-cells
slows after puberty and is basically
gone by age 65 which is one reason why
elderly people are more vulnerable to
infection well some new research
suggests that bodies with not so great
antibody levels can still have effective
t-cell responses against the virus so in
other words you haven't had it before
and you don't actually have to have
immunity to the virus your t-cells
already are able to fight this thing off
the study found that SARS kovat 19
specific cd8 t-cells were found in about
70 percent of recovering patients and
100% of patients had covered to specific
cd4 T cells importantly they detected
SARS covered to reactive cd4 + T cells
in 40 to 60 percent of unexposed
individuals suggesting cross-reactive t
cell recognition between circulating
common cold corona viruses and SARS
covered - so in other words if you had a
cold in the last couple of years your T
cells have maybe prepped for this thing
because you're cold it's a corona virus
this is also a corona virus so it is
possible that there is a heavy
percentage of the population that
already has sort of pre-existing
immunity think of all the zombie movies
that you've seen where there's a small
percentage of the population that was
resistant to the zombie plague and
they're the big survivors well what if
it turns out that half the population
already has a pre-existing resistance to
cover 19 so it's possible that herd
immunity is actually a lot closer than a
lot of people think as Jim Garrity
suggests it is reasonable to believe
that certain neighborhoods and
communities that were particularly
hard-hit in the early stages of this
pandemic may have reached herd immunity
or something close to it right we
already know that in New York there's a
good amount of data that suggests that
herd immunity may have already been
reached in particular areas but it's
possible and this would be the great
hope that you actually don't have to
infect 60 to 70% of the population with
cover 19 to achieve something kind of
approximating herd immunity and so what
you could see here is that as the
infections rise the death rates continue
to fall right they sort of plateau and
then they fall because it turns out that
number one the people who are now being
infected are the people who are more
healthy and number two it may turn out
that the infections rise and then they
sort of tail off because they're a bunch
of people who
maybe they're asymptomatic because their
t cells are actually strong enough to
fight off the infection so that is the
good news the bad news of course is that
we are seeing new hospitalizations
across the country he's a good news in
that and a secondary good news is that
the hospitalizations are not lasting as
long or having as dire in effect we have
learned how to treat this thing a lot
better at hospitals with that said the
day after California Governor Gavin
Newsome shut down a number of business
sectors in the state the LA County
Department of Public Health confirmed
that there were two 4244 new cases and
2,100 people currently hospitalized in
LA County that compared with only about
2600 new coven 19 cases on Monday of the
2,100 people currently hospitalized in
LA County 27 percent of those are
confirmed cases in the ICU 19 are
confirmed cases on ventilators according
to LA mayor Eric Garcetti there are only
766 hospital beds left for the region's
10 million residents but again that is
that is really sort of an exaggeration
of the case because again it's not like
there's millions of hospital beds
available they're all full that's that's
to say they're only 766 hospital beds
there is flex capacity there's ability
to send people home who you just don't
perform elective surgery on them okay
but none of that it's great news over in
Florida the the virus deaths have surged
as well it's about 132 deaths the number
one state by the way in terms of death
yesterday was actually not Florida was
California California had something like
139 Florida had 132 the question is
whether this is still rising or whether
this is plateauing okay but another
piece of good news right so piece of
good news number one is look at Sweden
hey everybody was ripping on Sweden
maybe Sweden is actually showing that we
are closer to her immunity then then we
think piece of good news number two is
that there's some very good news on the
vaccine front even dr. Anthony Fauci who
you could say is very hawkish on ANCOVA
19 he says that no matter how you slice
it this is good news there's an
experimental vaccine developed by the
NIH and moderna and key testing of the
vaccine is going to start around July
27th tracking 30,000 people to prove if
the shots really work in preventing
infections Tuesday they announced that
they had took it and they taken 45
volunteers they gave them all with AK
seen all 45 developed antibodies so this
would be obviously very good news that
does not mean that we are like a month
away from the vaccine
probably means beginning of next year
but that is good news as well so what
does this mean on on a practical level
well what it means on a practical level
is a couple of things one it means that
we should be optimistic about the next
few months right it means that we're
learning to treat this thing better it
means that there are a couple of things
coming down the pike that may change
things fairly radically it means that a
vaccine could be coming in the near
future which would obviously be very
good
and number two it means that some of the
sort of out size panic that we are
seeing over opening schools for example
seems a bit exaggerated shall we say it
seems like that some of this is
narrative driven la is not an immediate
danger of being completely overwhelmed
the way the New York was it just the
data don't support that the data don't
support the idea that Houston is it is
gonna be overwhelmed by I see use right
now or the Florida is gonna be
overwhelmed so should we be cautious
should we continue to be careful of
course we should and by the way we shall
get the flu shot when it comes to it
when it comes to the twin turret because
with hospitals already dealing with
coalbed having a secondary strain of flu
that really harms a lot of people and
fills up hospital beds would be a bad
thing as well but it is the is the sort
of wild pessimism of the media
completely justified given the numbers
right now I don't think so again I'm
gonna say wait a couple weeks remember
everybody was saying wait a couple weeks
before you start celebrating and I was
like okay right I'm kind of cautiously
optimistic but okay wait a couple weeks
before you start going into doom and
gloom mode wait a couple weeks before
you go into everyone's going to die mode
because the stats don't actually
demonstrate that that is that that is
the case right now what's gonna come
found the data by the way is that you do
have renewed lockdowns in certain places
in the country and people are going to
attribute any downtick that happens to
the renewed lockdown it's gonna be very
hard to make that fit if there's a
plateau over the next week or so like
it'll take at least two to three weeks
for us to see that any result of a
lockdown right everything is sort of
delayed by two to three weeks because
there's a seven-day infection period and
then it takes two to three weeks for
somebody to die god forbid once they get
cove in nineteen so if we lock down now
and then there's a decline next week
don't is tribuite it to the lockdown if
there's if there is a lockdown right now
and then there's a decline three weeks
from now then you could fairly think
that maybe the lockdown has something to
do with it so bottom line as I've been
saying all along I wish I had better
news for you here wait for more data
wait for more data okay in just a second
we're going to get to be politics
of the day first let us talk about the
fact that now that we're spending lots
more time at home you got to have the
most comfortable underwear on the market
the secrets is staying sweat free this
summer Tommy John's ultra breathable
underwear and also they have a great
bras for the ladies they have a range of
summer ready
breathable options but they're cool
cotton underwear for men and women is
like having your own on body AC my wife
can testify as to the quality of Tommy
John so can I at graces this magnificent
took us right now Tommy John's cool
cotton is made from premium natural pima
cotton for enhanced air flow it
evaporates sweat super fast keeping a
dryer cooler and more comfortable than
regular cotton if you want to add some
chill to your but when summer heats up
choose Tommy John cool cotton underwear
all of their layers are built for next
level comfort whether you're on the hunt
for lounge pants or lazy day joggers or
the softest zoom ready tees and polos
you've ever worn Tommy John has you
covered go check them out right now they
also have their best pair you'll ever
wear or it's free guarantee so you
really have nothing to lose here except
your discomfort Tommy John no adjustment
needed once you go Tommy John you will
never want to try other underwear ever
again for a limited time go to Tommy
John comm slash Ben get 20% off your
first order that is Tommy John comm /
Ben for 20% off Tommy John dot-com / Ben
alrighty so in other media news and that
this is I think the broader political
narrative that is of import today you
know we can put aside the cover 19 stuff
for just second because time will tell
who is right and who is wrong on that
one of the nice things about time is
that it does reveal truths when it come
to when it comes to the science and when
people in the media constantly say
follow the science follow the science
the science is leading in several
different directions here for all that
clear cut I have a feeling we'd all be
on the same page unfortunately it is not
all that clear-cut and everybody is
having to act in the absence of hard
information but when it comes to the
media we now have hard data and exactly
who the media are and what exactly the
media do so full disclosure upfront I
consider Barry Weiss a personal friend I
think that she's a very nice lady
I think that she is a really interesting
thinker she and I disagree on a great
deal but I also know that Barry has
basically been savaged from inside the
New York Times for years she's been
persona non grata inside the halls in
which she works for literally years at
this point I think it's fair to say that
Barry knew that she was living on
borrowed time there for at least the
last couple of years ever since she
wrote a piece frankly on the
intellectual dark web of which I'm a
part
shorty I don't believe I was even
mentioned in the pieces a lot of other
people work Joe Rogan was mentioned
Jordan Peterson and others barek got a
lot of blowback from that from her from
her fellow from her fellow staffers at
the New York Times and it never really
let up okay so yesterday Barry quit and
she issued a letter that really does
speak to it it's a brilliant letter
Barry's a very good writer
it's a letter that speaks to our media
moment and it speaks to our political
age and there's some really deep truths
here that I think have been completely
forgotten by our mainstream media who've
decided to basically become Teen Vogue I
said yesterday the New York Times you
just renamed itself Teen Vogue I really
failed to see the difference they got
Taylor Lorenz reporting on how
everything is cake I'm not kidding those
an actual report from the New York Times
and should take a picture of a cucumber
and somebody cuts it inside it's a cake
okay there that's that's over at the New
York Times or at Teen Vogue you
literally cannot tell the difference
between the editorials at Teen Vogue or
at the New York Times
Teen Vogue now just prints like straight
Marxist claptrap and so does in the New
York Times if you remove the the mast
then you'd have no idea which is which
particularly on the op-ed page so Barry
who writes at the op-ed page but
actually was doing fairly good reporting
on the op-ed page because the New York
Times simply won't report narratives
that it doesn't like so Barry ends up
doing a lot of that reporting over on
the op-ed pages meanwhile the New York
Times pushes on their non op-ed pages
actual op eds
right half of their mainstream news is
actually just op-ed stuff this is why
the 16:19 project which is just a piece
of historical propaganda and rewriting
in pseudo history that's treated as news
but Barry Weiss was on the op-ed page in
any case here's what Barry writes she
wrote a letter to pinched souls burger
who's the head of the the New York Times
and she said this it is with sadness
that I write to tell you I'm resigning
from the New York Times I joined the
paper with gratitude and optimism three
years ago I was hired with the goal of
bringing in voices that would not
otherwise appear in your pages
first-time writers centrists
conservatives and others who would not
naturally think of the times as their
home the reason for this effort was
clear the papers failure to anticipate
the outcome of the 2016 election men's
it didn't have a firm grasp of the
country it covers Dean Baquet and others
have admitted as much on various
occasions the priority and opinion was
to help redress that critical
shortcoming I was honored to be part of
that effort led by James Bennett I am
proud of my work as a writer and as an
editor among those I helped bring to our
pages the Venezuelan dissident weally
Arteaga
the Iranian chess champion dorsa Derrick
Shani
and the Hong Kong Christian Democrats
are glam also ayaan Hirsi Ali messyellen
Ishod saina Arafat Elma Baker rachel10
Hollander Maddy Friedman Nicholas P
Heather hi n Randall Kennedy and the
list goes on and on and on the lessons
that ought to have followed the election
lessons about the importance of
understanding other Americans the
necessity of resisting tribalism and the
centrality of the free exchange of ideas
to a Democratic Society have not been
learned instead a new consensus has
emerged in the press but perhaps
especially at this paper that truth
isn't a process of collective discovery
but an orthodoxy already known to an
enlightened few whose job is to inform
everyone else and this is such a key
point and buried hits this right on the
head over at the New York Times over in
the halls of media over at CNN and MSNBC
the idea is and this is all part of the
conversation we've been having about
canceled culture in the Overton Window
that the Overton Window is designed to
allow a robust debate over what is true
and what is not of what is correct and
what isn't to happen that's what the
that's why the Overton Window exists a a
tyranny of ideology suggests I own the
truth I am the only expositor of the
truth and therefore there is no reason
to have debate right there's no reason
to get on a stage with two people who
have conflicting ideas because we know
who is right and we know who's wrong and
providing that person a platform is
simply providing a platform to wrong
you've seen this from many so-called
journalists at the New York Times let's
say well why are we providing a false
balance between truth and falsehood
right balance isn't we provide a balance
between truth and falsehood balance is
just when we don't know the answer we
provide a balance okay but the New York
Times editors now suggest that they know
the answers to everything there's a
moral certitude that has taken place
that has taken the place of the general
commitment to ideological diversity that
originally was allowed because a
marketplace of ideas allows the best
product to rise forth but the New York
Times is barri points out has decided
that that idea no longer holds true that
they know the absolute truth it turns
out in retrospect making Nicole Hannah
Jones the effective editor of the New
York Times is a terrible idea and you
just boil it all down to that then
taking woke progressives who are
essentially activists and saying to them
you are going to dictate the truth from
on high and we are all going to sit down
here and if we disagree with you then
you get to stomp on us hey that is not
the way to
any sort of open journalistic enterprise
now Barry was a dissenting voice of the
New York Times all dissent had to go
away because dissent is not the highest
form of patriotism nor does the sense
even allowed in an area where you know
the absolute truth right if this is a
there's a religious aspect to this over
at the New York Times and in the
mainstream media where they know the
gospel truth and the gospel truth means
that everybody else is bound for hell
and so Barry continues along these lines
she says Twitter is not on the masthead
of the New York Times but Twitter has
become its ultimate editor as the ethics
and mores of that platform have become
those of the paper the paper itself has
increasingly become a kind of
performance base stories are chosen and
told in a way to satisfy the narrowest
of audiences rather than to allow a
curious public to read about the world
and then draw their own conclusions I
was always taught that journalists were
charged with writing the first draft of
history now history itself is one more
ephemeral thing ephemeral thing molded
to fit the needs of a predetermined
narrative that would be a slap at the
16:19 project obviously which has
decided that history is now malleable
and that history can be made to and
twisted to fit a narrative that is
absolutely untrue again ever every word
of this it's a brilliant letter by Barry
and you can see what the New York Times
lost in basically alienating her because
what happened here is that the editors
of the New York Times basically allowed
a malice shaming to occur inside their
op-ed pages and inside their newsrooms
and then Barry quit it's exactly the
same thing they did to their executive
editor of the op-ed page James Bennett
and they basically allowed the woke
staffers to make life so miserable that
James Bennett handed in his resignation
that's exactly what happened to Barry
we'll get to more of Barry's quite
brilliant letter in just one second
first let me tell you right now your
home a lot with your kids and that means
you need great children's literature but
you're having a tough time picking which
kids books are good and which kids books
are bad let me tell you about a
fantastic fantastic service it's called
literati literati is a subscription book
club that makes it easy to find unique
thought-provoking books for your kids by
delivering great stories directly to
your doorstep literati knows home
deliveries are critical for meeting your
needs for uplifting educational tools
during the coming weeks particularly if
you're in LA and they just shut down the
school district reading books together
will help create a time of adventure and
bonding for family and has real
educational benefits so let me just say
they personalize these things to your
kids so I have three children two only
two are old enough to actually read at
this point
but they have very different interest
literati customized exactly what would
arrive for my daughter and what would
arrive for my son and it's not just
books they have all sorts of kind of fun
gadgets and gizmos and stuff that your
kids can play my kids are super into it
all the books they sent are brilliantly
picked all of the all of the objects
that they sends my kids are still
playing with them literally months later
it's just fantastic
you only keep your favorites and then
you send the rest back for free literati
beats the Amazon list price on these
books that means you're only paying for
the books your kids love and you're
getting a lower price with schools and
libraries closed literati is working to
get books in the hands of families who
don't have access to educational
materials of their own for a limited
time go to literati calm slash apparel
for 25% off your first two orders this
is their best offer available anywhere
to get it you have to go to literati li
te ra TI literati comm slash appear for
25% off your first two orders that's
literati comm slash bureau i can't speak
of them highly enough it really is a
fantastic service my kids have been
getting a huge kick out of it go check
them out right now literati comm slash
shapiro okay so back to Barry Weiss's
letter over at the New York time so
Barry quit yesterday and she has this
entire letter and she says my own
fluorescens wrong thing have made me
subjects of constant bullying by
colleagues who disagree with my views
they have called me a nazi and a racist
I've learned a brush-off comments about
how I'm quote writing about the Jews
again several colleagues perceived to be
friendly with me were badgered by
co-workers my work and my character are
openly demeans on company-wide slack
channels we're masthead editors
regularly weigh in there some co-workers
insist I need I need to be rooted out if
this company is to be truly inclusive
while others post X emojis next to my
name presumably because they want her
axed still other New York Times
employees publicly smear me as a liar
and a bigot on Twitter with no fear that
harassing me will be met with
appropriate action they never are there
are terms for all of this unlawful
discrimination hostile work environment
constructive discharge I'm no legal
expert but I know this is wrong I do not
understand how you have allowed this
kind of behavior to go on inside your
company in full view of the papers
entire staff and the public and I
certainly can't square how you and other
times leaders have stood by while
simultaneously praising me in private
for my courage showing up for work as a
centrist and at an American newspaper
should not require bravery is Barry
Weiss writing to the publisher of the
New York Times
part of me wishes I could tell my
experience was unique but the truth is
that intellectual curiosity let alone
risk-taking is now a liability at the
Times
why edit some
challenging to our readers or write
something bold only to go through the
numbing process of making it
ideologically kosher when we can assure
ourselves of job security and cliques by
publishing our four thousandth op-ed
arguing that Donald Trump is unique
danger to the country and the world and
so self-censorship has become the norm
what rules that remain at the times are
applied with extreme selectivity if a
person's ideology is in keeping with the
new orthodoxy they and their work remain
unscrutinized everyone else lives in
fear of the digital Thunderdome online
venom is excused so long as it is
directed at the proper targets this of
course is a hundred percent right op eds
that would have easily been published
just two years ago would now get an
editor or a writer in serious trouble if
not fired if a piece is perceived as
likely to inspire backlash internally or
on social media the editor or writer of
what's pitching it if she feels strongly
enough to suggest it she was quickly
steered to safer ground and if every now
and then she succeeds in getting a piece
published that does not explicitly
promote progressive causes it happens
only after every line is carefully
massaged negotiated and caveated it took
the paper two days and two jobs to say
that the tomcod an op-ed fell short of
our standards we attached an editor's
note on a travel story about Jaffa it's
the Israeli city of Jaffa shortly after
it was published because it quote failed
to touch on important aspects of Java's
makeup and its history but there's still
mud appended to Cheryl Strayed fawning
interview with the writer Alice Walker a
proud anti-semite who believes in lizard
Illuminati the paper of record is more
and more says Barry Weiss the record of
those living in a distant galaxy one
whose concerns are profoundly removed
from the lives of most people this is a
galaxy in which to choose just a few
recent examples the Soviet space program
is loud in for its diversity the daxing
of teenagers in the name of justice is
condoned and the worst case systems in
human history include the United States
alongside Nazi Germany even now I'm
confident most people at the Times don't
hold these views yet they are cowed by
those who do why perhaps because they
believe the ultimate goal is righteous
perhaps because they believe they will
be granted protection if they not along
is the coin of our realm language is
degraded in service to an ever-shifting
laundry list of right causes perhaps
because there are millions of unemployed
people in this country and they feel
lucky to have a job in a contracting
industry or perhaps it is because they
know that nowadays standing up for
principle at the papers does not win
plaudits puts a target on your back to
wise to post on slack they write to me
privately about the new McCarthyism that
has taken root at the paper of record
all of this bodes ill says Barry Weiss
especially for independent-minded
writers and editors paying close
attention to what they'll have to do to
risk advance in their careers rule one
speak your mind at your own peril rule
to never risk commissioning a story that
goes against the narrative rule 3 never
believe in editor or publisher who urges
you to go against the grain
eventually the publisher will cave to
the mob the editor will get fired or
reassigned and you'll be hung out to dry
for these young writers there's one
consolation as places like The Times and
other once great journalistic
institutions betray their standards and
lose sight of their principles Americans
still hungry for news that is accurate
opinions that are vital debate that is
sincere I hear from these people every
day
an independent press is not a liberal
ideal or a progressive ideal or a
democratic ideal it's an American ideal
you said a few years ago I couldn't
agree more America is a great country
that deserves a great newspaper miss
Barry Weiss writing against the
publisher of the New York Times on her
way out just setting fire to the place
none of this means and some of the most
talented journalists in the world don't
still labor for this newspaper they do
which is what makes the illiberal
environment especially heartbreaking I
will be as ever a dedicated reader of
their work but I can no longer do the
work you brought me here to do the work
that a tough Oaks described in that
famous 1896 statement to make of the
columns of the New York Times a forum
for the consideration of all questions
and public importance and to that end to
invite intelligent discussion from all
shades of opinion Oakes idea is one of
the best I've encountered
I've always comforted myself with the
notion the best ideas went out but ideas
cannot win on their own they need a
voice they need a hearing above all they
must be backed by people willing to live
by them sincerely Barry okay so Barry
what Barry has been I know Barry Barry
has been essentially verbally threatened
on the slack channels of the New York
Times for years at this point people who
work at the New York Times have attacked
her publicly again I run in publication
if my writers were attacking each other
on openly like in the media or even
back-channel if they're a slack board
where somebody was just getting
routinely beaten up those people would
be fired okay that's the way that
normally these companies work but that's
not the way these companies work anymore
they are run by the woke staffers and by
the editors who are too cowardly to
stand up to the woke staffers they've
decided to shut the Overton Window in
moral certitude that they are right and
everybody who disagrees is absolutely
wrong okay so Barry is not wrong about
her characterization here and frankly I
don't blame her for leaving she was
under again this sort of pressure every
single day like all the time over at the
New York Times because the New York
Times has basically
become a college paper it's just a
college paper at this point that doesn't
mean there aren't great reporters over
there there are some great reporters
over there it does mean the New York
Times is now a shadow of what it once
was although you do have to ask at a
certain point whether the New York Times
learned any of its lessons over the
weekend I watched a movie called mr.
Jones excellent movie by the way I
should make it a thing I like it's it's
terrific it's a movie about the
revelation of the Ukrainian Holodomor
wrote which was Stalin basically
starving millions of people in Ukraine
in order to usurp all of the produce
from Ukraine and use it to build
whatever he wanted to build and the
mainstream Pulitzer prize-winning
reporter from the New York Times was a
guy named Walter durante who was just a
shill for the Soviet regime the movie
really takes this on and there's a
fantastic scene where there is a sort of
acolyte of Walter durante who's talking
to the journalist who breaks the story
about the Ukrainian famine and that
guy's name is Gareth Jones and she is
telling him that basically you got to
crack a few eggs in order to make an
omelet and he says well hold up a second
what if you're wrong what if it was we
need a better world but what if you're
wrong and it finally occurs to her that
maybe she could be wrong that any system
that requires the breaking of the eggs
in this way maybe she's wrong about the
system well over at the New York Times
they have never let go of the certainty
that they are right about the system
it's just a new brand of write about the
system Walter Durant he was sure that
the Communists were right and so he was
willing to overlook the Ukrainian famine
and now you have a group of people over
at the New York Times the Wilkes
staffers who hate America so much they
hate the American system so much they
wish to tear it down they believe that
it is rooted in racism sexism bigotry
homophobia needs to be torn down and
that is a moral certainty and that means
that if you have to abuse people who
disagree with you you do it it means you
have to basically passive will
aggressively threaten people at your own
publication you go ahead and you do it
because you have the moral high ground
and it doesn't matter who has to suffer
in order to make that happen it doesn't
matter if the Overton Window has to shut
the Overton Window shouldn't even exist
it shouldn't exist there's one approved
opinion and it is the only approved
opinion and now it's not just Barry over
at the New York Times this is happening
- so Andrew Sullivan a man with whom I
have had significant disagreements
remember Andrew Sullivan who has been
interesting on many issues but also is
the same guy who once suggested that
Sarah Palin's daughter was not actually
her own daughter and ultimately Andrew
Sullivan has kind of a quirky history
but a lot of his writing is really
interesting he writes over at New York
Magazine he's been speaking out about
canceled culture
now he has quit New York magazine he
announced he's leaving at the end of the
week he said this will be my last week
in New York magazine I'm sad because the
editors I worked with there are among
the finest in the country I'm immensely
grateful to them for vastly improving my
work I'm also proud of the essays and
columns I wrote at New York magazine
some of which will be published in a
collection of my writing scheduled for
next year the underlying reasons for the
split are pretty self-evident okay and
again it's pretty obvious exactly what
happened here he felt the same way in
New York Magazine that the that Barry
Weiss felt at the New York Times and he
wrote about Barry Weiss actually in
mid-june and about the general
perspective of the New York Times said
that they have a view of the world with
moral clarity but no moral complexity
talking about the 16:19 project and the
view of people like Nicole Hannah Jones
so the New York magazine editor-in-chief
of Adam David Haskell responded to
Sullivan leaving and his response is
everything his response is just as
important as Barry's letter because it
really does demonstrate the thought
processes that go on inside the
editorial halls of power or cowards
surrender to the woke staff who are
intent on creating a new hierarchical
orthodoxy in thought
we'll get to that in just one second
first reminder my new book how to
destroy America in three easy steps it
goes on sale Tuesday Tuesday less than a
week away July 21st 6:00 p.m. Eastern 3
p.m. Pacific we will be doing a virtual
live signing event on the day of release
with your purchase of a signed copy you
can write in a question which may be
read and answered as I sign your book
live on the air magical you can
pre-order your signed copy and write in
your question at daily wire comm slash
Ben the book covers two fundamentally
different visions of America that's what
we're talking about right now one vision
is the unifying traditional vision of
America where we say that we have a
shared philosophy based on the
Declaration of Independence we have a
shared culture where we respect each
other's rights we have a shared history
we're all part of the same stream of
history
none of this ignores the problems with
America but it recognizes America is the
greatest nation in the history of the
earth and then there is a second
narrative and a second vision and that
narrative is that America's history is
evil its philosophy is corrupt and its
culture of Rights is merely a cover for
power this would be the New York Times
16:19 project in your tenth editorial
board robin's angeles white fragility
these are classic examples of the of the
vision I call disintegration assist
integrationists they're people who want
the country to fall apart disintegration
is to use weapons like canceled culture
the leading or silencing anyone
or anything that disagrees with them to
build their whole new world order how to
destroy America in three easy steps
details how the disintegration is vision
has gained the ascendancy
it offers a penetrating view I think of
our country at this time and also it
offers the antidote simply reading the
book is the antidote again that is daily
we're calm / been to order your signed
copy today and join my live signing on
Tuesday July 21st now if you're not
already a daily where I remember you
should also consider getting a readers
past a daily wired calm fantastic value
three bucks a month when you sign up you
get that first month for only 99 cents
you also get access to our mobile app
articles ad free and access to exclusive
editorials like the satire from our
friend Andrew Clavin medical experts now
believe Joe Biden's election will
completely cure Croatoan virus well that
make it the second thing to care
coronavirus kneeling for woke purposes
also cares coronal virus if you haven't
already checked out the readers past
head on over to daily wire.com and sign
up for just a dollar you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so the letter in response to
Andrew Sullivan leaving from David
Haskell is the editor over at New York
Magazine is everything right it is
everything because it's an admission
that everything that Barry Weiss says
and then Andrew Sullivan says that our
media have basically become just
loudspeakers for one point of view
willing to shut out anybody else at the
behest of the loudest voices who claim
that if you refuse to acquiesce to their
requests then they will destroy you as
insufficiently well that they are
absolutely accurate in that assessment
so here's what David Haskell just wrote
he said hey everybody as you may have
seen Andrew Sullivan's last week will be
this one as he finishes the feature
we've published in the print magazine
and writes a final column the decision
to part ways was mutual Andrew and I
agreed that his editorial project and
the magazine's the overlapping in many
ways were no longer the right match for
each other with the news of Andrews
departure I'd like to share some
thoughts about my approach to politics
coverage more generally I'm trying hard
to create in this magazine a civil
respectful intellectually honest space
for political debate I believe there's a
way to write from a conservative
perspective about some of the most
politically charged subjects of American
life while still upholding our values I
also think our magazine in particular
has an opportunity to be a place where
the liberal project is hashed out which
is to say not only championed but also
interrogated our readers regularly
encounter some of the best writing
coming from the left from our politics
writers on Intelligencer and the cut as
well as many of our cultural writers on
vulture that we also have some writers
who share our values but not always the
politics of most of our staff is to my
mind a credit to the organization and
the benefit to the reader I will
continue to push us to publish work that
challenges the liberal assumptions of
much of our readership but Botts writing
here comes the rule right as soon as you
make a statement then you have but but
generally obliviate and and just
destroys the rule but publishing
conservative commentary or critiques of
liberalism in the left in 2020 is
difficult to get right and thoughtful
well-meaning people can come to
different conclusions about it how to
weigh the value of plurality of
political opinion against other
journalistic and community values so
question what is the what is the other
competing journalistic and community
value and we're not talking about
printing neo-nazi stuff we're talking
about printing I mean Andrew Sullivan is
at best mildly right-of-center
at best okay then the notion that he's a
wild-eyed Reagan conservative is just
crazy it's not true okay but Andrew
Sullivan is like out of bounds for a New
York magazine
again that sentence is
how to weigh the value of plurality of
political opinion against other
journalistic and community values
whether our current publication does in
fact create the environment I'm trying
to foster by that that big mealy-mouthed
language is safety ISM right that if you
print something it's damaging to others
it's it so just to be straight there are
a group of people on the Left who
believe that Barry Weiss writing about
the writing about the IDW or me on a
college campus talking about abortion
this is threatening the safety of others
whereas if you go to one of my lectures
and you burn crap outside not
threatening others or if you go on the
slack channel at the New York Times and
you tweet Barry Weiss's name next to
axiom oh geez that's not threatening
right safety ISM is the idea that
anything somebody says you disagree with
makes you unsafe but the same people who
are claiming that Barry's is whining too
much and and Andrew Sullivan is
complaining too much about the hostile
work environment all these are the same
idiots who are suggesting we need to
rename master bedrooms because master
bedrooms are reminiscent of slavery even
though they have nothing to do with
anything okay so this New York magazine
editor says what to think of certain
writers in particular I understand some
of the staff comes down differently than
I do on these subjects I am grateful for
their private and direct feed book
feedback as opposed to on Twitter which
is a terrible place to litigate anything
so that is his acknowledgement the
people on the inside over in New York
magazine were yelling at him and now
he's gonna cave to them so that that is
that is the the nature of our media at
this point and it's been hard far and
wide and we're now living in a culture
in which people are being forced to lose
their jobs for like the most ridiculous
reasons now let me make clear there are
reasons why in the media you should lose
your job hey I'm not saying that there
is no such thing as the Overton Window
or that there is no opinion that is
outside the Overton Window I'm not
saying that there aren't opinions for
which the blowback is absolutely merited
I mean I absolutely think that there
there is such a thing as an opinion that
is so clearly horrible and wrong that
even granting it a granting it a
platform you doing it I'm not saying you
should be de platform from a general
public kind of forum like a Facebook or
Twitter or something but like listen
there's an Overton Window a Daily wire
I don't print everything at the Daily
where because we have a set of values
and if you don't abide by our values I'm
not printing it we are openly partisan
we are openly conservative and I'm not
saying
if you're the Atlantic that there aren't
things that the Atlantic doesn't have a
right to basically reject right or the
New York Times does have a right to
reject if Richard Spencer writes a piece
about how white supremacy ought to rule
the day I don't think the New York Times
has an obligation to print that I don't
think for example that Viacom CBS has an
obligation to continue to continue to
employ Nick Cannon after Nick Cannon
cannon went on a podcast and talked
about the Jews right cannon had worked
as executive producer and chairman of
TeenNick a spinoff of the Network
Nickelodeon geared toward teenagers he'd
also been a host and executive producer
of the MTV comedy wild night out a
Viacom CBS spokesperson said in a
statement the company categorically
denounced all forms of anti-semitism
because basically Nick Cannon went on
Twitter and suggested that the true
Hebrews were black people right he's
essentially parroting the nonsense from
black Hebrew Israelites and he also
suggested that Jews control business is
my understanding he said in an interview
at The Washington he said apparently
it's o Kenan was interviewing a rapper
named Richard Griffin known as Professor
grift Griff Griffin left the hip-hop
group Public Enemy in 1989 after he said
in an interview the Jews are wicked and
we can prove this and that the Jews were
responsible for the majority of
wickedness that goes on across the globe
speaking to Kenan Griffin doubled down
on his past remarks about Jewish people
on the music and media industries and
Griffin said I'm hated now because I
told the truth and Kenan said you're
speaking facts there's no reason to be
scared of anything when you're speaking
the truth he also said it was a shame
that Louis Farrakhan had been silenced
on Facebook despite the fact that Liu's
Farrakhan is of course a brutal vicious
anti-semite who's compared to Jews to
cockroaches Cannon said in the podcast I
find myself wanting to debate the idea
of banking conspiracies about Jews he
says it gets real wishy and washing
uncleared to me when we give so much
power to the days and the days then turn
into Illuminati the Zionists the
Rothschilds and then he said you can't
be anti-semitic when we are the somatic
people that's our birthright so if
that's truly our birthright there's no
hate involved now can Viacom CBS fire
Nick Cannon over that sure I mean by the
way I defended the right of I was very
controversial design I defended the
right of CBS to let go Roseanne Barr
after Roseanne Barr tweeted out racist
stuff about Valerie Jarrett right
because the bottom line is that when new
information is added to
Stu of a person's public profile it has
to do with the actual ability to perform
this job and when that new information
is so vastly outside the window of
normal discourse then there can be
blowback so I'm not arguing there can't
be blowback
I'm just arguing that what the left has
done is they've expanded the definition
of outside the Overton Window such that
the Overton Window is a pin point it's a
pin point right if you don't agree with
the writings of Tanya Hoshi Coates you
are outside the Overton Window and it
really is that simple there's like a few
key litmus tests and if you don't
fulfill those litmus tests then you are
cast out okay any system that lumps
together in the we should be able to
cast them out category Andrew Sullivan
Barry Weiss and Nick Cannon is a bad
system of thought it's a bad system of
thought and that is the system that we
are creating right now I'm not saying
you can't draw lines I'm saying that
where the left is seeking to draw lines
is basically around that pinprick of
thought that they agree with how do you
know this okay though the worst case of
cancel culture that I've seen in recent
memory this is amazing so this one is
from the San Francisco Museum of Modern
Art according to Reason magazine until
last week
Gary girls was senior curator of
painting and sculpture at the San
Francisco Museum of Modern Art he
resigned his position after museum
employees circulated a petition that
accused him of racism and demanded his
immediate ouster Gary's removal from SF
MoMA is non-negotiable read the petition
considering his lengthy tenure at this
institution we asked just how long have
his toxic white supremacist beliefs
regarding race and equity directed his
position curating the contents of the
museum this accusation is a pretty
serious one so what exactly did he do
their sole complaint is that he
allegedly concluded a presentation on
how to diversify the museum's holdings
by saying quote don't worry we'll
definitely still continue to collect
white artists that's the whole thing he
said we're gonna try and purchase art
from people who are not white to
diversify our holdings also will still
buy some art from white people because
white people still make some good art
okay he was forced to resign his job he
was forced to resign his job over this
that's utterly insane he actually said
this he said I do not believe I've ever
said it is important to collect the art
of white men I have said it is important
that we do not exclude consideration of
the art of white men that in and of
itself was considered so far outside the
Overton Window this guy lost his job at
the San Francisco Museum of Modern Art
okay
to utter ly crazy it's just crazy this
is the world that we are building right
now another case over over the weekend
hank berry and reporting for daily wire
on Monday at Seattle business owner
issued a public apology for her
dreadlocks after she was vilified on
social media
Rachel Marshall founder of Rachel's
ginger beer in Seattle responded on
Instagram to critics who viewed her
dreadlocks as cultural appropriation one
critic wrote Seattle we got to talk
this person owns a particular business
here in Seattle with multiple locations
she's a white woman with dreadlocks and
allegedly gives her product to cops for
free and has always confused me we have
seen this woman speak and cozy up
regularly with other people in the
community and no one has confronted her
about her choice to willfully
appropriate black hairstyling we aren't
in a post-racial utopia there's no
federal law to protect black people from
being penalized for their natural or
protective hair styling hell we're still
trying to convince everyone black lives
matter and these kind of posts forced
her to then write hello everyone it's
Rachel I've come to understand far too
belatedly my hairstyle is harmful no it
isn't no it's not it's a hairstyle gang
it wasn't that she made her hair into a
swastika or something she had she was
wearing dreads like this is insane it's
it's completely crazy
she says it's clear I've been stubbornly
resistant I sincerely apologize to those
I heard I'm deeply sorry for the pain I
caused members of the african-american
community who have been and still are
discriminated against and mistreated for
having dreadlocks and I'm so sorry it
took so long to admit and address my
mistake I have an appointment to remove
my dreadlocks and more broadly I'm
committed to earnestly listening to and
from the voices and lived experiences
different from my own I never want to
cause any harm
right the argument about harm has now
expanded dramatically obviously right
harm is anything I don't like and non
harm is anything that I want to cancel
that is how the definitions have shifted
incredibly incredibly wildly this is
really really dangerous stuff for the
country there is a priesthood here that
gets to determine what is acceptable and
what is not and those standards don't
have to even be connected remotely with
anything realistic it's just whatever
the woke bosses say today and everybody
attempts to avoid their scorn they
attempt to avoid the eye of raw in the
end there's only two ways this goes one
you
and you surrendered because you don't
want to be guillotined or two there is
indeed a mass cultural uprising at
exactly the sort of nonsense and that
mass cultural uprising has to happen
right the hell now it has to happen
right now has to happen yesterday so
good for Barry Weiss good for Andrew
Sullivan good for those hundred and
fifty-three center-left people who wrote
for Harper's and welcome to the club
guys and you got to recognize something
okay in solidarity lies power so you may
not like me and I might not like your
viewpoints the difference is I've been
fighting for your right to speak what
you've had to say for years so it's
about damn time that we all get together
and recognize that while we may disagree
on a wide variety of issues on this we
agree the Overton Window has been closed
too far by people who are ideological
fascists they wish to shut down debate
that is their goal the Liberals and the
classical liberals are on the same side
of this particular debate otherwise
there will be no debate and the people
who ends up winning are the people who
are just willing to utilize power in
whatever in whatever convenient fashion
they can okay we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel why douse key technical
producer austin stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by micro Romina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen